we're only two films into the multi-film
franchise that Avatar is becoming but
some characters are almost certainly
destined for greater things on the world
of Pandora spoilers ahead
one of the brightest highlights of the
original Avatar was getting to know the
navi the greatest promise of the
franchise's premise lay in the feline
species and their Charming emotionality
that is one of the several reasons why
the introduction of the mechaina clan of
Navi means so much to both Avatar the
way of water and the franchise moving
forward we knew from the existence and
lore of the torukh mocto in the first
movie that there were other Navi Clans
but we never got to see them in detail
being set almost entirely in mechanic
territory the second film finally allows
us to see how other Navi live and it is
pretty wildly different in addition to
their many differences in lifestyle the
metcaina are anatomically different from
the forest-dwelling navi they're
differently colored possess more
efficient lungs thicker thin-like arms
and legs and even stronger fin like
Tails it's probable that the navi Clans
likely split apart millions of years ago
impressively even after all that time
and evolution the many Navi Clans still
live in relative
if The Insider look at the lives of
mekaina Navi and Avatar the way of water
opened the doors to a larger Pandora
than the introduction of the tolkiens
blew that door clean off Pandora was
special enough when it seemed to be
simply an Earth-like EXO moon with its
own sentient species but now that
another entirely unrelated sentient
species exists in the form of the whale
like tolkiens the world of Pandora means
so much more for one thing the tolkiens
force a major change to Modern
hypotheses of astrobiology sentience is
evidently more common than we ever
imagined and clearly comes in many
shapes and sizes but for another more
narrative related points the tolkiens
are almost certainly going to play a
huge role in future Avatar movies
perhaps the most central theme in avatar
The Way of water is the relationship
between pacifism and morality Jake
chooses to give up his fight and flee
the RDA and although that sounds Noble
in a sense it simply ends up bringing
his War to a new Clan the tolkiens are
symbolic standings for Jake choosing to
forgo all violence in their culture
regardless of motivation which
ultimately results in many of their
deaths as the rebellious aggressive acts
of block and pyakonville sometimes
violence in the right context and for
the right reasons is actually the answer
among the four silly children Avatar the
way of water makes it clear that some
are destined for more than others aside
from the obvious point to make which is
that mitan's death most likely rules him
out of any major roles in the
franchise's future Kiri and loock are
shown to possess unique gifts that make
them important figures in the coming
conflicts for a walk that gift comes in
the form of the spirit bond he's able to
form with piking the lone Tolkien who is
Outcast for fighting back against the
RDA laloc was raised as an underdog the
second son who was always in the shadow
of Natale making him more flawed tragic
and sympathetic than his brother
partially because of that Misfit
childhood Loach is well suited to
understanding and bonding with piking
the two meet as Mutual Misfits and both
are more prepared than their
collectively minded peers to combat the
rda's increasing threat they cannot take
whatever they want
this is
despite the Sully family's central place
in the overall story of the Avatar
movies much of what makes them so
special is the Partnerships and bonds
they form with others that makes a
figure like loock who is likely to
become one of the next great Heroes
almost impossible to mention without
also recognizing his pal pyeken between
Lok and paikin it is the massive Tolkien
who has more to lose more to gain and
more RDA equipment to smash than the
lock and his contribution to the war
cannot be overlooked pykin's story is
tragic one of an individualist who acted
against his society's laws only to save
his friends and family by bonding with
Loach and helping the Sully family repel
the RDA from the mechanus waters pyekin
proves himself a more valuable asset
than all of his fellow tolkiens combined
as well as a much more apparent hero
in addition to their four children Jake
and naturi also care for the human child
named spider more than any other
character in avatar The Way of water
spiders very existence is packed with
meaning in a way he fits the Trope of a
child of Two Worlds a human raised on
Pandora by a navi fluent in their
language and immersed in their culture
and is therefore virtually guaranteed to
help bring about a much-needed peace in
the franchise's future but spider is
also Colonel porridge's son franchise
architect James Cameron is a well-known
environmentalist and that personal
philosophy shines through in the Avatar
films that makes the most likely and
logical conclusion to the film's a peace
between humanity and every living thing
on Pandora and elsewhere assuming that
to be true then no other character is as
well positioned to bring about that
peace than spider
the metcalina are ruled by a royal
family led by their patriarch tonawari
of course as Jake and natiri make clear
tonawari himself has a leader his wife
Ronald not only is she the power behind
the throne but she's also the Clan's
official sahiq or spiritual leader it's
immediately apparent from the way that
the mechanic tree torawari and ronal
that the pair are respected in their
community and that the word is law with
ronal as the head of such a formidable
force that makes her potentially the
greatest threat to the RDA and to
Humanity's presence on Pandora in
General on the real world side of things
Ronald's appearance in at least one more
Avatar is confirmed and hinted at beyond
that
Believe It or Not death was not the end
for Colonel courage even though the
Marine died at the end of Avatar shot
through the chest by two of natiri's
arrows he lived on Via a recombinant his
own Navi Avatar the irony in his new
life as Navi is obvious and becomes even
more so when he bonds with his own
Banshee a major rite of passage for
Native Navi even reborn as a navi he
spends Avatar the way of water seeking
the same Vengeance against Jake Sully he
sought for most of the first movies even
so his tough outer shell may end up a
bit softened by the film's end thanks
mainly to The Compassion of spider as
well as possibly his newfound connection
with Pandora and biosphere korich was a
meaningful character when he was
relatively simple human villain if he
ends up a recombinant navi who helps
bring down the RDA from the inside or
fostering peace between the RDA and Navi
he'll go down as one of the franchise's
most meaningful characters ever Recon
jairim in an avatar body that's a Walton
mix give me the Goosebumps
with Colonel porridge in the nascent
stages of a potential character Arc that
may just end with him siding with the
navi a new top villain needs to arise to
take his place and even if porridge
remains arcless and every bit the
two-dimensional villain he first
appeared to be a five movie series will
need more to sustain its conflict that's
where General Ardmore comes in the new
Big Bad introduced in avatar The Way of
water and based on rank alone she has
more to throw at the navi and their
allies than quarge ever could in terms
of the Marine Corps hierarchy Ardmore
outranks quoridge by a long shot in
other words if you thought Colonel
courage was bad in the first movie you
haven't seen anything yet
there's something special about Jake and
netiri's eldest daughter Kiri starting
with the fact that she's not their
biological daughter Kerry's biological
mother is the navi Avatar of Grace
Augustin and Kyrie's father remains
unknown on top of her unusual Origins
she also possesses uniquely powerful
empathic powers and they undoubtedly
mean a lot to the next few Avatar films
at one point Kiri even reveals to her
father that she can hear and feel Ewa
herself and it seems more than likely
than not that she isn't just
hallucinating we've seen her ability to
speak with and control the life around
her and we've seen the all-encompassing
neural network shared by the pandorian
biosphere so the idea that she can speak
with the planet itself or even its deity
is not so far-fetched
as surprising as it may be Avatar the
way of water may have actually confirmed
the existence of the navi Chief deity
Ewa the first movie explained the vast
network of electrochemical connections
shared by all living things on Pandora
which the navi referred to as Ewa I hear
her heartbeat
[Music]
with young Kyrie able to hear and feel
and even control the living things
around her she essentially proves that
Ewa is real and Ewa has at least a
rudimentary mind of her own while we've
seen alleged evidence of ewa's
Personality before most notably when she
seemingly spurred the forest creatures
to Aid the navi in their battle at the
end of the first movie we can now more
or less confirm that Ewa is not just a
name to be applied to unlikely acts of
Fate she's a real being with real
feelings and through Kiri we may yet
hear her speak
foreign
[Music]